à peine le fermier ainsi le dos tourné
que de petits doigts curieux se balade
jusqu'au bout claire a du mal à
apprécier mais les autres sur catégorie
c'est très bien c'est meilleur que les
normales le lait vendu dans le commerce
à moins de boue sous celui de la ferme
c'est avant tout à cause du chauffage
140 x 2 et pendant trois secondes pour
le lait de non conservation suffit
souvent à céret et de qualité gustative
alors pour flatter le palais tout en
supprimant les intéristes le buste
nouvelle réplique la microfiltration le
lait est filtrée dans des ports très
très petit ce qui fait que c'est
uniquement une technique physique et il
n'y a pas besoin de le chauffer et à
partir de là le lait n'étant pas traitée
qu'à une conserve absolument toutes les
caractéristiques qu'il a au moment où il
est produit par la vache ce mot vient
tout juste de naître
et comme peut aussi faut il nous
certifie bien impossible de retrouver
dans le lait de ses vaches des
pesticides ou des antibiotiques mais
pour le goût c'est plus la qualité des
vêtements qui joue un rôle on recherche
une fleur qui soit la plus riche
possible plus varié possible
c'est vrai qu'on allait faire et qu'on
s'aime il ya une douzaine d'espèces
différentes de plantes
il est presque deux fois plus cher mais
pour les citadins
les nouveaux choix dira au rayon frais
et privilégier les lait entier
c'est dans les matières grasses que se
concentrent toutes les saveurs la 13e
semaine du goût elle commence
aujourd'hui pour donner à nos enfants le
plaisir des saveurs comme disent les
organisateurs
parmi les nombreuses manifestations les
nombreux produits le lait on disait que
les jeunes préfèrent le goût aseptisé
des briques industriels et bien
apparemment il n'en est rien laurence de
chef maï à l'uci à peine le fermier
assise le dos tourné que de petits
doigts curieux se baladent juste pour
goûter claire a du mal à apprécier mais
les autres sont catégoriques
si le lait vendu dans le commerce à
moins de goût que celui de la ferme
c'est avant tout à cause du chauffage
140 100 degrés pendant trois secondes
pour le lait de longues conservations
suffisent pour en altérer les qualités
gustatives
alors pour flatter le palais tout en
supprimant les bactéries il existe une
nouvelle technique la microfiltration le
lait est filtrée dans des ports très
bref petit ce qui fait que c'est
uniquement une technique physique et il
n'y a pas besoin de le chauffer et à
partir de là le lait n'étant pas traiter
bien une conserve absolument toutes les
caractéristiques qu'il a au moment où il
est produit par la gauche seveau vient
tout juste de naître
et comme tout le troupeau il est
certifié bio impossible de retrouver
dans le lait de ses vaches des
pesticides ou des antibiotiques mais
pour le goût c'est plutôt la qualité des
aliments qui joue un rôle on recherche
une flore qui soit la plus riche
possible plus varié possible
c'est vrai qu'on les prairies qu'on
s'aime il ya une douzaine d'espèces
différentes de plantes
il est presque deux fois plus cher mais
pour les citadins amateurs de bon lait
mieux vaut temps choisir un au rayon
frais et privilégier les lait entier
c'est dans les matières grasses que se
concentrent toutes les saveurs